zum glück gibt es auch noch ein paar
schöne meldungen in diesen insgesamt so
trostlosen zeiten
unser geliebter alt kanzler gerd
schröder ist neuerdings ein veritabler
instagram star und seine dienste
aktivitäten verpassen ihm sogar
plötzlich ein junges funky image für
mich ist das fast schon kunst und damit
ein klarer fall für aspekte mit dietmar
wischmeyer
[Musik]
dies ist die rührige geschichte eines
altkanzlers der sich für seine partei
neu erfunden hat vom knallharten
genossen der bosse fand der geld zurück
in das einfache leben eines spd
mitglieds von dazumal der für seine frau
auch schon mal einen frischen feldsalat
pflückt sie ist es auch die ihm sein
neues leben geschenkt hat nummer fünf
wir sie zärtlich nennt hat ihren gatten
gelehrt dass es noch andere dinge im
leben gibt als gaspipelines durch die
ostsee zu prügeln
gerade jetzt im herbst die roten
hagebutten über all das sind keine guten
ich finde sind schön
sie haben übrigens doppeln die welt
gefährlicher sind als sie von rosen bis
hierhin vielleicht hagebutten sind rosen
und zwar deren früchte und haben keine
dornen sondern stacheln
aber was soll's muss man nicht so genau
nehmen putin hat schließlich auch dornen
und naughty dog ist gefährlicher als
hagebutten
am abend steht der neue gerd am herd und
schmurgelt für mausi eine leckere pfanne
mit selbst gesuchten pilzen
hoffentlich hat er da vorher mal in ein
botanisches bestimmungsbuch geguckt die
deutsche sozialdemokratie kann dankbar
sein für ein altkanzler in der sie
zurück führt zu ihren wurzeln als wahlen
noch im kleingartenverein gewonnen
wurden und brave gattinnen ihren männern
noch am küchentisch die ungefähr tten
haare rauften dieser neue schröder hat
auch seine liebe zur deutschen lyrik
wiedergefunden
es ist sei moment mal ich bin etwas
abgelenkt was macht bitte diese rosa
hütte zwischen dem gestrüpp ganz zum
haustier rezept ist er scheint doch noch
nicht der alte haudegen
wer jetzt kein haus hat baut sich keines
mehr
wer jetzt allein ist
lange bleiben lange allein bleiben und
mit diesen weisen worten zu den
kommenden koalitionsoptionen der spd
verabschieden wir uns vom hausbesuch
beim orakel gehört so haben wir noch
irgendwas zum thema hagebutten vergessen
sein das sind herr frantzen bild sich
nochmal hagebutten sind die früchte und
es sieht auch nicht witzig tschüss bis
zum nächsten mal dann besuchen wir
altkanzler merkel bei der kartoffelernte
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]